as the underpinnings of some democratic
countries are being called into question
china is holding out its model as a
thriving alternative
over the past four decades beijing has
increasingly asserted its power on the
global stage
and is now on course to become the
world's biggest economy
two years sooner than predicted
pre-pandemic
for china this success legitimizes its
model as an alternative to the liberal
values of the west
the world is undergoing changes unseen
in a century
and now is the time for major
development and major transformation
but for the us and its allies this
authoritarian blueprint is seen as a
threat to their democratic ideals
democracy doesn't happen by accident we
have to defend it
fight for it strengthen it renew it
we have to prove that our model is in a
relic of history
we used to think that the us china
competition was mainly about economic
leadership or mainly about
military primacy in the western pacific
clearly it's a competition of systems as
well
and whether those systems can perform
adequately
in the 21st century and the global
pandemic
and its aftershocks have only height
intentions between these competing
systems
this is the first global crisis in which
america
failed to lead the west when historians
come back to look at the issue of covid
and geopolitics they will ask was
20 20 21 were those pivotal years
was that the year when suddenly asian
countries china in particular really
began to seem as if they were back on
top
so what does it mean for the world as
two superpowers go head-to-head
not just over trade or borders but
ideology
[Music]
three hours four minutes 32 seconds and
counting
right on time as far as the astronauts
in the 1960s
while the us was putting a man on the
moon
china was struggling to feed its one
billion people during the decade-long
cultural revolution
in the 1960s both countries were going
through
periods of social upheaval the u.s
was dealing with the racial reckoning
the civil rights movement but at the
same time
there was a favorable economic
environment
china on the other hand had a period of
social upheaval
where the economy was uh completely
stagnant and
ruined by collectivists agricultural
policies in particular that caused
widespread famine
a lot of the educated people in beijing
were taken out to the countryside
there were purges all throughout the
party all had a big cost on the economy
after the death of mao zedong in 1976
it was the reforms of deng xiaoping that
led china to prioritize economic growth
even if it meant going against core
communist ideology
dong was one of china's most influential
leaders
ever and basically responsible for the
china
that you see today this was a night that
was going to be different
during the cultural revolution he was
shunted aside by mao
himself and then later brought back and
rehabilitated
and he went on to really spark the
reforms and reform and opening a period
that led to the economic miracle that
we've seen in china
delighted in putting it on for the
photographers and waved enthusiastically
to the crowd
he brought china back on the world stage
and
put it out in front of global investors
for the first time really
since the cultural revolution
[Music]
the country opened up to private
business and foreign investment
dominant state-owned banks turned
savings into financing
for roads rail links and ports
and foreign firms were forced to set up
alongside a local partner
encouraging the transfer of technology
as a result the economy grew 90-fold
over the next four decades
dunk shelton never had an absolute kind
of blueprint about what china would look
like
at the end of the reform process it was
very
experimental so certain reforms
were introduced in particular localities
first to see if they would work
and it once they seemed to work then
additional
localities were allowed to experiment
with it so that's the case of special
economic zones is a good example of that
it started out with four special
economic zones that allowed foreign
direct investment and then later on
you know coastal cities and now pretty
much all of china so
that experimental sense and almost
improvisational
approach towards governance is a
hallmark of reform era china
for many outside china it was expected
that as the country's economy became
more capitalist
its politics would become more
democratic
other countries in asia south korea for
example
were dictatorships at one point um they
opened up their economy they became
known as
asian tigers and democracy uh sort of
came with that so many people thought
the more china exports the world the
more
it'll open up politically and kind of
follow the path that some of those other
countries in asia had
had taken that wasn't the case however
you know china maintained political
control
and this control was maintained by using
a blueprint known as the china model
a blend of state-directed capitalism and
political authoritarianism
that consists of four key elements to
keep the one-party state
thriving focusing on the economy
stoking national pride keeping party
discipline
and allowing no challenges who may be
critical of the government
all day troops have patrolled the
streets firing indiscriminately
to keep people off the streets tiananmen
was was a part of that
you know the fact that they used a
deadly force
to stop demonstrations in their tracks
they also crack down on free speech
they were able to do that by delivering
for the people
in a way that you know the masses were
seeing economic gains they were seeing
real improvements in their livelihood
and that has underpinned the
legitimacy of the communist party even
as it's
it's really eliminated all sort of uh
political dissent
um both from without and within the
party over the years
beijing also argues its model removes
the short-term demands of an election
cycle
creating the stability needed to plan
and execute long-term strategies
but in the more than seven decades that
the ccp has been in power
experts do point to an evolution in the
chinese authoritarian system
i think it would be misleading to talk
about a monolithic china model because
so much
has changed over different phases of
the people's republic of china's history
many social scientists have come up with
various
terms to modify it to qualify the nature
of authoritarianism in china so it may
be
consultative authoritarianism fragmented
authoritarianism
responsive authoritarianism
decentralized authoritarianism
and what all of these adjectives get at
are
the different spaces that exist in
china's political system
for adaptation for responsiveness
for even participation and even policy
influence
that's embedded within the system
at the turn of the 21st century both the
chinese and u.s models appeared to be
flourishing
but then the 2008 financial crisis hit
lehman brothers a 158 year old firm
filed for bankruptcy stoking a rivalry
between the superpowers
and their models of government the 2008
financial crisis
seemed to call into question multiple
aspects of the international system
at once it certainly called into
question the allure of the u.s
economic model which was seen to have
caused the crisis
in the first place it raised the
possibility that authoritarian
capitalism
might outperform liberal democratic
capitalism over the long run
and then not least of all it convinced
many chinese officials that the united
states was in geopolitical and
geoeconomic decline
and so if you look back at the the
critical inflection point in a variety
of chinese
efforts to revise the terms of the
international system you're simply being
more open about the idea
that china might eventually seek to
displace the united states you can trace
those back to the aftermath of the
global financial crisis
[Music]
and now a new global crisis has thrown
the china model back into the spotlight
and initially it didn't look so good the
silencing of dr
lee wen liang the whistleblower who
tried to warn china's authorities about
a deadly coronavirus outbreak
confirmed the opacity of beijing's
system
the model itself leads to a lack of
transparency
that ultimately raises questions about
china's response to the virus opening up
the books and showing everybody what
happened
is just not in the dna of the chinese
authorities to kind of reveal
what happened because possibly it could
show something much worse that they
screwed up and that would be
you know devastating for them
politically which is the ultimate
weakness of the china model in the sense
that
you know everything about it is geared
toward keeping the commerce party
in power but that same china model
also allowed the government to enforce
the first large-scale lockdown in modern
times
and quickly summon mass social
compliance that helped to contain the
virus
i mean that's remarkable infrastructural
power but that wasn't just because the
government's powerful it's because
rank and file health workers public
security people
transportation people they were all on
board
participating in enforcing those
lockdowns
and limiting mobility so from from the
government's perspective that's an
example of
we're all in it together we all share
the same goal
it's actually extremely expensive and
delegitimizing to just rely
on on brute force to enforce a
particular policy so you
you actually need cooperation by
societal actors to provide that
reality check and also buy-in that
they're they're part of the process that
the government actually cares about
their concerns
and will be responsive when they when
they bring up issues
although doubt surrounds the accuracy of
numbers reported by china
it was inevitable that comparisons would
be drawn with its rival superpower
i think there's a big false positive
that people look at the
current situation with kovid and they
draw the conclusion that because the
world's
leading totalitarian country has done
better generally at fighting kobe than
the world's leading democracy they draw
the conclusion
that democracy is not good at dealing
with things with kobud and that is
patently rubbish
in general if you're in an autocracy
you're in a worse situation yes okay
china did okay but you wouldn't have
wanted to be in iran during this
you wouldn't run to be in any of the
stars you wouldn't want to be in north
korea you wouldn't want to be in russia
so on the whole the countries have done
well australia new zealand singapore
japan south korea
these are all democracies the levels of
difference
are so colossal between the countries
that did this well and the ones that did
it badly
that the biggest answer in all this is
whether you had governments that worked
and knew what to do
it was the notable absence of the us
government under president donald trump
to lead a response during the early
stages of the pandemic
and the subsequent catastrophic death
toll in america
that caused many to question the
strength of its model
including beijing in some ways the
coveted pandemic is a replay
of the global financial crisis in the
effect that it has had on chinese
behavior
in the near term at least and so the
global financial crisis convinced
chinese leaders
that they had a window in which they
could behave more assertively in areas
from the south china sea to the east
china sea and beyond
and reap new geopolitical gains covet
has clearly had the same impact on
chinese leaders
this assertiveness under xi jinping
means doubling down on border disputes
in the south china seas
and along the border with india while
also looking to consolidate power in
tibet and hong kong
xi jinping has really emphasized this is
to overcome
what they call the century of
humiliation in china where
a bunch of foreign powers basically ran
over china forced them to sign traded
agreements that were exploited and this
really
drives the chinese political environment
everything that's done cannot be seen to
be bowing to the west
china needs to assume its rightful place
on the world stage
and you see china now on a global stage
challenging you know the us leadership
role and the role of the west more
generally
in trying to tell china how to run its
government
how to run its country and how to run
its economy
during certain periods of chinese
history many of its policies both
domestic and foreign were indeed driven
by ideology because after all people's
republic of china was founded on
communism but now
it's not as if today's chinese communist
party is interested
in exporting socialism or fomenting
communist revolutions around the world
their policies actually are not
ideologically driven
i think a lot of their behavior however
is nationalistically driven to protect
china's
interests and so i think if you asked
people in china you know is there an
ideological conflict
they might say well yes the ideology is
actually coming from the west
as this ideological rivalry increases
it's spilling over into many aspects of
the global economy
why is technology such a key flash point
in the u.s china relationship
in part it has to do with the fact that
technological innovation in areas like
artificial intelligence
will shape the balance of economic and
military power
in this century but it's also because
those technologies have massive
implications for the ideological
struggle between authoritarianism
and democracy china is for instance
trying to develop what can best be
described as a high-tech police state at
home
that uses a combination of big data
artificial intelligence and other
technologies
to monitor and control the behavior of
the population
technology is just one of an increasing
number of flash points
as china accuses the us of stoking hong
kong's pro-democracy protests
washington condemns the mass detention
of uyghurs in xinjiang
the biden administration is also taking
action to protect its model
such as increased spending for
manufacturing self-sufficiency
and strengthening ties with taiwan
we are in the midst of a fundamental
debate about the future and direction of
our world
that autocracy is the best way forward
they argue
and those who understand that democracy
is essential
essential to meeting these challenges
and i believe
that every ounce of my being that
democracy
will and must prevail this isn't the
first time that americans
and citizens and other democratic
societies have worried that autocratic
models will be the wave of the future we
saw something very similar during the
great
depression we saw something very similar
in parts of the world
after world war ii what we realize in
retrospect is that the weaknesses
of democracies always look more
pronounced in the moment because those
weaknesses are out there for everyone to
see
whereas autocratic regimes like china's
tend to assiduously conceal
their own failures and their own
weaknesses
and with potential financial and
demographic challenges looming
there may be other threats to the
sustainability of the china model
that could arise from within the country
the china model is you know you can grow
the economy
you know while maintaining a one-party
rule
yet at the same time you know there's
real questions about
how long you can continue this as your
population gets wealthier as it gets
more educated
as it gets more integrated with the
world and
has ideas from from other places and has
demands for
better livelihoods and more say
at the same time how does xi jinping
transfer power one day and when does he
step down
the sustainability of the china model is
an open question at this point
no two leaves in the world are identical
and no
histories cultures or social systems
are the same each country is unique
with its own history culture and social
sciences
and none is superior to the other
i think the lessons if you look back
through history are really clear
plagues are things that either cause
the downfalls of particular orders or
cause a rethink
so when you have these momentary
disasters that's the moment when you
you do wake up by any measure you look
at the democracies of this world
you look at europe and america together
and they are stronger than china
if you have a west that begins to reform
its governments that begins to
talk about the importance of freedom
that begins to
talk to like-minded countries about
values like democracy and so on but it
also makes its government more efficient
then that is a is a much more um
competitive power than what china has
faced thus far
you